have you seen those those youtubers that
do like the day the simpsons died where
they find the exact episode where
it ceased to have any relevance or
interesting things to say i look forward
to this episode of
play watch listen being that moment
jumping one episode
right now
there's there's different opinions in
there on which episode of simpsons was
like the last good episode of the
simpsons i've seen some of those videos
as well they don't seem to agree do they
austin they've got they've all got
different things
yeah but they're always interesting
videos yeah on like the the yeah the the
sort of the the the moment that
seemingly
the
the sharks it's not being political
no and it's
like there was a lot of the original
writing staff kind of moved on from the
simpsons so after about it's like season
eight or nine they a bunch of people
like quit i think that's why oh yeah you
can you can really feel i think it's i
think 10 has like a few trailing yeah
pretty great classic episodes but it
starts to fall off i remember thinking i
can't really remember the specifics of
that episode but i do remember there
being a
um an article a few years ago that was
like things that have
been happening on the simpsons the last
five years that you will have missed if
you dropped off at season 10 like
everybody else
and one of the things that they brought
up that i thought was interesting was
um the simpsons started making episodes
that tried to come to a sort of
moral conclusion at the end
that was one of the things they stopped
doing probably in response to the rise
of popularity of family guy and stuff
like that they kind of
you know they kind of made it a little
bit more jokey and a little less classic
well the original simpsons was they were
all morality plays right basically every
episode
an outcome yeah no all commentary
where i feel like they stopped having i
don't disagree i've never heard the
hypothesis of like it was this episode
and this definitely happened but it did
like i'm definitely aware of that i
don't feel like they have
statements now it's like receiving
whatever that was you don't know when it
happened but it did happen it certainly
did i'm going to make a youtube video
essay about that
it was the contention of that article
though
the contention of the article was
that
this this second this this this recent
one i was seeing where they said that
the simpsons has actually kind of gone
back to form
in that regard you know starting in
season [ __ ] 29 or whatever um
to make it you know a little bit more
about there being a sitcom-esque like
the way south park always used to you
know i learned something today yeah at
the end of each episode uh they've
started to go back to that and they said
it's actually the show is benefit from
it feels more like it's one of those
things that you don't you don't realize
until you see it
that's part of what makes it feel like
the simpsons right oh it's interesting
this is interesting i haven't watched an
episode with other than random accidents
of hotel room cable i haven't seen
uh a recent episode in probably
18 years or something
keep up to south park right
but what you keep up to date with south
park
oh hell yeah although i haven't watched
the very very newest actually funny
enough
our jolly holly
you know mr
mr smirking baker here in the corner
messaged me to say dude there is a
new south park that you would have to
watch
um
and so i'm on it
as i
as i uh
i am in my hotel room right now
why did that just happen i lost austin's
audio i feel like i should just address
at this point because we're probably not
going to keep all that tech support in
oh it says your internet connection is
unstable exciting um everybody's in
different places everybody hi welcome to
play watch listen i'm alana i'm a video
game writer that's austin wintry he's a
video game composer and that's mike
bithell he's a video game director
um i'm dog sitting for a friend
and i can hear myself speak
which is confusing
because i don't know how to use the
setup austin where are you
i'm at a hotel room in london why
i can't say
excellent great
how about you where are you at i can't
say no i'm in i'm in the us
i'm visiting my partner um and i can't
say why either because you're serious
and clearly
troy
what are you up to wow cold shoulder
rude he's ignoring us sorry rude but
look how much he's enjoying he's some of
the time of his life
he's very smug about it it's a very cute
picture of him it's good
it's a good picture i just googled troy
baker christmas um and i did intend to
do this episode with a christmas hat
clearly didn't do that i went shopping
well i could not find one anywhere in
like four stores
like in the hour before this episode
very disappointing i
have something
to show you
you were in america and couldn't find
christmas yeah regalia i think i don't
know about you i think maybe america has
cancelled christmas i don't know i think
there's i think christmas has been
counted in america i think there's but
there was christmas stuff for sale
before
on christmas or something that's the
vibe i'm getting i don't know if it's i
don't know if it's true um yeah it sells
out really fast
that's why i think it works
very very sold out very fast yeah um
so i'm sad that troy's not here but this
episode does go up on christmas day so i
thought this was extra nice i had
something right congrats for hiding from
your family everyone watching this
you gotta go back down [ __ ]
the host participant thing won't let me
host disabled participant screen sharing
it sucks because i'm the [ __ ] host
so i can't show you the thing that i
wanted to oh but i can share it with you
and i will publish it on on youtube i
basically had uh someone i've been
working with for a really long time his
name is matt ringstead
animate
um an excerpt from the podcast it is
about a minute long and i think it's
incredible
oh my god i'll send it to you guys as
soon as i can and yeah i'm gonna publish
it on youtube as well
uh it's super neat so merry christmas
everyone sorry you guys can't see it
right now maybe you'll also see it
christmas day merry christmas i feel
like but that but the the execution of
this delivery of it is very in keeping
with uh absolutely
yes i love that this is this our last
episode for the year
surely right surely is
not technically if we record next week
but i like the idea of us sending off
2021 with
tech issues
that's great
i love that for us um
however
arcane well
can you send a can you send a link or
something
ready yeah i'm not i'm not ready to yeah
i'm expecting arcane level production
values here i think if you guys watch it
at the same time
that's what i'm going to do
yeah and then i can edit the reactions
in okay or real-time arcade as we have
to request access so let's do that
oh no um
sign in to view
uh so yeah i'm expecting has raised the
bar for animation so like that's the
level i'm expecting here so honestly if
it's not really that level then
i'm going to be disappointed okay hang
on i play a request i've requested it uh
but i don't own it so it says i was
requesting
for me yeah your email
i disagree
this is blowing my mind
[ __ ] where
using somebody else's pc is really hard
we really set ourselves up for success
here this year okay i hit download key
thing is planning it's planning it's
always put yourself put the parts
together it just
just shows how elaborate our production
meetings are really
well organized
we've got a very good team assembled for
the uh
the show is gonna be so upset about this
like the uh i know exactly all their all
their best laid plans and we just plowed
right through it there's a live producer
in the room that definitely exists
ah [ __ ] so i've downloaded it with
the intention of publishing wait no i
just i just got a notification i think
that that my approval request was
accepted
how
i'm assuming that
your animator is sitting there guarding
there
you got it too yeah
okay that's great news for us okay so if
me and austin sync our play
yeah then you can put it wait hold on
it's it's giving me you know what i'm
going to do i'm going to download it
because streaming on every dropbox is
just the thumbnail is superb um i really
tried to talk
i recommend the same mic
yeah i do know
i've had many frustrated streaming
attempts but yeah this first frame is
very promising this is the first frame
gets me excited that that's i feel like
i i should address in advance that there
is no austin in it because you were not
here when this happened so i've made a
second one that has austin in it
but it's not done yet
how's how how is this how is this i
thought austin was kind of
always present yeah
yeah got the one time he's not wow okay
i know should we three two one it
did i leave early or something
yeah i think okay yeah sorry mike go
ahead count it off
three two
one
play from like okay i got 60 bucks
i'm over my lines
plural i had to do to make this 60 bucks
my birthday present christmas present
whatever
i'm gonna discuss
the voice of a type
i got 60 bucks i got 60 from my grandma
before she died
[Laughter]
you know i'm 16 years old
[Laughter]
hi i like the grandma very much i know
i let me finish this cigarette really
quick
listen to me i'm ready to get 60
the bowl cut um
i'm like closing my eyes and picturing a
16 year old and i'm a very big fan of it
it's very good
i guess 60 dollars
we should be done now if we all time
that correctly that was amazing
oh so matt ringstad i found because he
listened to podcast unlocked which was
the xbox podcast that i did at ign
and he just animated something one day
and he's only gotten better over time
it's like been very cool watching
someone get better and better and better
then he started working with faunt house
and then i was like
could you make some of these for
playwatch listen so i intend to maybe do
like one every couple months
and just remember it's so good yeah
little play watch listen animated
adventures cause i feel like they're
very cool i did i just say in ventures
it's so confusing when you can
hear yourself speak um i i i think he
gets especially
excellent points for
the interpretation of what troy needed
to do to get 60 dollars
the bloodied
burying of a body was a very
i did not direct that that was all him
um
yeah he he did everything i was just
like here's a clip
do whatever you want
and i think i've literally had to leave
early like once
you managed to find i know
i'm sorry
i feel very targeted
the next one i promise has austin
content um
but he also was like can you give me our
heights was the one thing that he asked
for was how tall we all are so that when
we're standing next to each other it's
actually like pretty spot on so i sent a
picture but i don't know
is toronto taller than you mike
is uh i don't know
in the pictures i have he is but aren't
you like six three i'm like i think i'm
like six six three but i'm maybe i'm
wrong maybe but i'm not measuring myself
not troy bank is gonna be taller than
six three i'm pretty sure he's six four
but i thought you were i thought you
were easily six four or more mike so now
i'm completely i don't know i'm tall i
don't know how much longer i am and troy
though or shorter it says also the
internet says troy is also six three
okay i'm five all i know
all i know is that i'm basically six one
and it's very weird to me that i am not
like i'm not there i'm i'm i'm i'm not
even like a contender for the tallest
one of the group and that's very rare
for me
so i'm also because i'm wider i'm like
i'm like
short you know troy's troy's tall in the
way that he looks like he's been resized
just vertically because i've been
resized like horizontally as well like
it
creates that illusion i i don't look
tall i look like i'm closer to you than
i am that's what it is
like there's something wrong with your
video it's like a perspective
[Laughter]
it's true actually that photo of us from
the um the wick event um
at uh e3 like the the press thing that
was you know from before it was all kind
of officially out there
i shared that photo recently and i was
looking at it again and i was like you
look
massive you literally look like you're
just standing literally it is that you
were just standing closer to the camera
or like somehow somehow we're like
shooting with different lenses
when you're making video games and you
accidentally import something at like
one i like 1.2 1.5 times the size by
mistake and you have just this this
weird one prop that's too big that's me
that's that's that's me in my life yes
basically
i'm not a small dude
but somehow
i look significantly different stuff
yeah there's no there's no going around
it so it's a nightmare for on many
levels it's great mike confirmed lodge
yes
um
there you go there's the very technical
answer for him
but uh yeah huge thanks to matt for
making that i thought i would make it
and hopefully present it to you guys but
i need to fix out this host issue i'm
going to email you about it um in any
case yeah why don't we actually talk
about arcane
we could also talk about nfts what kind
of existential crisis are you like
trying to head in today it's fun isn't
it
the two things that are at the full
front of my brain and the matrix i'm
interested in your take on nfts actually
i know i've talked very boringly about
twitter bella i'm interested in what
your take on nfc's
well i just tweeted just before we
started the show
um
[Music]
people like i don't understand why all
these gaming companies are trying to get
involved in nfts when clearly audiences
aren't going to be happy about it or
whatever
they don't care
um
right now and i don't actually know that
this works long term right now nftes are
extremely profitable for
ubisoft for example if they're like you
buy this cloak this cloak costs a
hundred dollars um and then
the audience who buys this cloak will
resell this cloak for a thousand dollars
and we'll take a cut of every sale so
there's
selling an individual it's still a
[ __ ] micro transaction just prettier
they're selling an individual
microtransaction
for
more money
um for an audience who will potentially
even start generating their own so
potentially we could see a world where
the audience will start making the
cloaks and trying to sell them uh some
games have already done this minecraft
for example yeah in counter-strike yeah
yeah there's a massive steam workshop
community of people that make custom
weapons this is so similar to
counter-strike it's a perfect parallel
that anyone's thinking of it differently
to what counter-strike has been doing
for forever is strange
the
that's why it doesn't strike me that's
why i don't understand why it's so like
offensive because i go it basically is
just a new technology of the same idea i
agree it's just a micro transaction just
a different yeah
um however
the thing
that works against it that i think is
going it costs money in a way that i'm
confused about why people aren't talking
about and mike i feel like you could
speak to this
if we create these nfts and i get my
cloak in fortnight that i want to take
into god of war for example
uh and i'm like hey i bought this why
can't i put it into god of war that's
how nft is supposed to work i'm supposed
to be allowed to take my cloak into
everything people think that you can
just kind of pick that up yeah and just
sort of put it into the other game
of course that's going to cost
developers selling t's right now think
that like they fully think
yes genuinely i've had that pitch at
dice like from the evangelists i've i've
watched and i will not i'll be good i
won't name i've watched an nft
evangelist which is about two three
years ago pitching the owner of a
massive aaa studio with a massive aaa
franchise and saying to this guy
you're going to be able to buy guns for
your game and they're going to be able
to take them and put them into another
person's game and that that owner of the
ceo beer and be like
technically how
why would i want that
who's going to pay for it yeah it makes
no sense at all
epic
does
want it and i think ubisoft could do it
in their own games
is like
this is just fancy
micro transactions that in theory
being on the blockchain etc the
individual users can make money from i
don't see how that's different to a
million things we've already done
minecraft skins that stuff already
exists
the thing that does get me that i think
a lot of people aren't thinking about it
all
is the well i can put it in any game so
the issue with putting your cloak into
god of war after it's in fortnite is the
amount of time that it takes an artist
or slash an entire team to make that
cloak work in god of war is not
necessarily going to be financially
worth it whatsoever
for and certainly also you multiply it
infinitely by the number of exactly no
it's not going to happen it's not going
to happen so technologically that
doesn't require for devs in the long run
is the problem
when initially it's like sure that's a
lot of profit because you're selling
individual items for a lot more money
you couldn't even do this with music you
couldn't even like if you wanted to play
back i want to listen to
you know bears god of war music while i
play fortnite even that
wouldn't work because even though wave
files are simply wave files that's not
how game scores exist they're not just
playing through a
a spotify playlist of sorts it's it's
all scripted like which are attached to
in-game hooks that are specifically made
based around what the game is supposed
to do so it's like even and any art
assets and things like that are going to
be far more proprietary and complicated
than music is going to be so it's so
it's i've never heard anybody make that
that claim though that's a bizarre
that's being that claims to be made by a
lot of the nft people
even if not everyone is
is making that claim that is the claim
that they are excited about
that is yeah i don't even understand the
excitement either the rest of it is why
would i want that yeah the rest of it i
don't want that in god of war
i want like a i want like a last of us
shiv in god of war like what the [ __ ]
that's not so i want to know what are
games let's roll back to austin
so austin asked the question like why
i don't understand why people are
annoyed about this because it's
pre-existing technology i think the
there's a couple of answers to that why
people are irritated by this one is
um obviously negative effects on the
environment yeah the environmental
impact it's terrible when you say it's
terrible there's always five people jump
on you on twitter and go well they're
working on making it better
cool but until that actually is the case
it's terrible for the environment that's
that's just the truth of it um the the
but i think the main reason game
developers are annoyed by it
is that it's not it's it's honestly
that's dishonest that it is just the
functionality we already have on servers
all of the claims about blockchain and
why it's better are so easily and
obviously dismissed by anyone with any
technical skill or grounding in
programming or game development or who's
ever had a minecraft server just
practically i can log everything the one
the one that gets thrown at me a lot
whenever i criticize it is some people
saying yes but on the blockchain you own
it
and that's so fundamentally wrong and
misled misleading i mean the idea so the
idea would be by a gun of call of duty
and then you would own that gun and if
you were banned from the server because
you're an awful human being or whatever
um you would still have that gun and no
one could take it away from you and
technically what actually would be the
case is you'd have a token saying that
you owned that gun but your gun
only exists within the game of call of
duty and if you can't play the game your
gun is meaningless your gun doesn't
exist out it's schrodinger's gun at that
point like until you can actually play
the game the object you own has no value
or meaning
which is which is where all of this
falls down at which point this is
literally exactly the same functionality
as if you just bought something on
you know activision store
for the game like and that's where it
goes that's why that's why you see a lot
of basically most people who actually
make video games kind of saying this is
nonsense the other aspect i think is is
worrying and potentially risky for the
industry
is the enormous amount of illegal
activity around
these things actual literal money
ordering money laundering ponzi schemes
and you can the the ubisoft things are
really worked out in a really
interesting way so ubisoft just did
there was it ghost recon
they did they did some yeah some yeah
they did some crypto stuff for they did
basically they did some nft uh dlc
essentially exactly the model we're
talking about here
and they lost a lot of money on doing
that because every time you mint so
every time you burn some trees down so
that you can set so you put something on
the blockchain that costs an amount of
money they had to mint all of these
items they were going to sell
and then in terms of the money made from
those items they actually made less than
they spent minting them so it was
it was like 10 sales
it was ridiculous and the reason for
that well you could look at it a couple
of ways you could look at it in a
generous way way into the field which is
oh well ubersoft just didn't do it right
you know they didn't do it properly
but if you look and if you track the
data floating around with most of this
nft stuff what you very quickly realize
is it's a lot of people selling to each
other or indeed to themselves and
creating the illusion that stuff is
selling essentially people are selling
items to
uh anonymous people occasionally what's
hilarious is sometimes people have
messed up and not logged out of their
account before doing this so you have
lots of examples of like people buying
their own thing that they made for ten
thousand dollars because they didn't log
out of their account into their
anonymous account before they did the
transaction
that even happens on stockx as soon as
you bid on a pair of shoes they've been
on their own shoes to try to outbid you
and you can tell
capitalism's been playing these games
for a long time and they work but what's
interesting about the nft stuff and the
blockchain stuff is it kind of is the
worst possible version it's the most
because again it's unregulated
i think taxation's starting to kick in
now which is the point where you know
everyone's gonna be making less money on
it and therefore probably it's gonna
start to die a death but yeah it's it's
that's why it's frustrating it's not
frustrating because it's inherently
terrible nfts their their technology
technology
in this case i'd say by definition
doesn't have it's not inherently good or
bad but so far it's been used for snake
oil salesmen exclusively there's not
really been a use for it that's valid or
useful that can't be done cheaper easier
and with better customer service
by other means the other thing i'm in
agreement people make the claim so i'm
surrounding now apologies this is my
fault um but the people make the claim
that um nfcs are somehow more generous
to the end consumer that because because
it's on the blockchain it's inherently
better owned by the users so it's more
consumer-friendly
which is ridiculous if i sell you
something
on your credit card and i misled you
lied to you
or spent your money done something awful
you can track that you can go to an
authority you can you can get me in
trouble you can get your money back you
can get your insurance to pay off
there's a lot of systems in place to
protect you from me as a company
defrauding you
if it exists in the magical world of
blockchain right now there's very few
protections your money goes your money's
gone you're you have way fewer consumer
rights in that space it's a kind of it's
a fun libertarian fantasy until
something goes wrong and then there's
just no one to protect you and it's wild
west
i think there's a lot of interesting
value in the suggestion that um
blockchain takes
ownership out of the banks um and i can
understand how people get behind that
right like i understand why it's
appealing um the nft's thing
i hate
doing this but um
i saw people saying i i hate saying that
because it's like who how many people
whatever um but for the purposes of like
whoa people really saying that there was
a conversation that i just read on
twitter just as an observer did not
partake in was just reading some very
pro nft people talking about video games
and they were like well every publisher
will end up putting nfts in their games
because you wouldn't want to lose our
audience the amount of money that they
can generate
technically yes from a publisher's
standpoint you can see again people are
buying micro transactions that they've
already bought a million times before
for more money um the first one in
theory not so bad and then when you get
people to
it's so hard to talk um
when you get people to start creating
their own
that's when ubisoft just banks in the
same way that the playstation store is
banking or the xbox store is banking or
steam is banking with 30 of every sale
of every game right
but they're like well then every person
will end up having nfts and will support
my cloak across their games because they
don't want to lose out on us
you're so much smaller than you think
you are so so so much smaller there are
not enough people that that would ever
matter people are still going to play
video games even if they can't get their
cloak in a game i don't buy that you're
not gonna play the next
last of us just because you can't have
joel wearing a bright pink cape but i
think that's where i think that's and
that's i've seen this point made i'm
stealing this from others but i think
it's so true
that's to me where it betrays not from
the
not from players like i'm not dismissing
players who who are excited by a cool
new thing although it is weird to watch
players begging for more drm it's a very
strange culture for sure they've made
micro transactions appealing bolts it's
interesting when you see the people
pitching these ideas
uh or talking about like the exciting
potential of basically of owning stuff
and
it kind of betrays that these are not
necessarily people who want to play
games to have fun or be entertained it's
all you can earn money while you make
while you're playing games or you can
show off that you have an awesome tape
in a game these are not people who are
interested in games as a medium from
like a creative or entertainment point
of view there's always been people i
mean again using using counter-strike as
the example again like that's not a
new demographic but i agree with you
alana that it's also far from the
dominant one
um
yeah
uh
and and i agree those people will
continue to exist i don't remember i've
said this on this show before but i had
the thought of like
of all the conversations i've had about
how the stock market influences the
games industry
i've been like to people i've been you
know had conversations where they've
been like well then should i buy shares
in this publisher and
like actively participate in
you know trying to give them more money
when they do something i like or
whatever
um and
it occurred to me that even if all of
the people who were invested in
ea were huge gamers
i think by the end of
a week maybe 99 of them
would turn and would go
oh i can make money from this and they
would stop sticking to the morals and
they would end up being looped into the
game
and i think
yeah and i think that would happen vast
vast vast majority of people that like
you could get gamers involved in the
stock market
and and participating in the games
industry in a different way in a
financial way outside of just purchasing
video games
um and they would all
very quickly be like yeah when it's your
money in the game i think you feel
differently right like if it's your if
it's your pension for sure you you
you're if you're putting your pension
into something if you're going well how
financially secure am i going to be as a
as an older person yeah you're going to
care less about whether the new call of
duty sucks or not like by definition
those are those are two completely
different tiers of problems to be
thinking about right like yeah most
adults would appreciate that like it
matters less on a personal level if call
of duty is good than if you're gonna and
once you're starting to make those kind
of mental leaps you're yeah like you say
you're you're going to think like an
investor because you're an investor i
think you'd lose it really quickly you'd
be like oh how many micro transactions
do they have so that i can
cash in on that make sure we're
profitable it would happen so fast um
and yeah nfp nfts is just a fancy micro
transaction it's very weird to me that
people don't see it that way like to
your point austin about counter-strike
counter-strike is the perfect example of
something that's been happening for a
really long time that
somehow some people
really want who hate microtransactions
somebody just asked me do you think that
nfts could get rid of microtransactions
in free-to-play games
what
yeah they are micro transactions they're
more expensive unregulated micro
transactions where you can be if you
thought loot boxes were bad my god like
that's the other thing is when you see
like
literal definitions
micros
transaction sorry legally it's not
gambling to be clear because because
it's not legally anything because it's
unregulated so i can't accuse you of
gambling
it does strike me though that over the
long term it does offer the potential to
be the same thing as microtransactions
but somehow the better version because
there is that sort of
that
you know authenticated ownership aspect
of it that microtransactions doesn't
even aspire to conceptually how is that
how in what way will it be different
because if you wanted to buy something
that's uniquely yours like when i look
at like a look at the popularity of star
citizen where it's like
you know for 200 bucks you can get this
ship that will never be available again
and people buy them on that basis
and you know say we will about that
whole story but as a concept people like
having something that's unique and
special especially in the context of a
big communal game like that yeah so it
struck me as a thing where
the the technology is sort of
specifically geared towards saying you
know okay yes everybody acknowledges
digital copies are not exactly hard to
make but in the context that so like
selling nfts of a jpeg of your painting
makes a lot less sense to me than
selling nfts of like this cloak in our
you know free to play
mobile mmo or whatever it struck me as
you know it's not i've never been that
type of gamer i don't look deeply enough
into the
um underlying you know business models
or things like or like you i i've heard
these claims of how easy it might make
things like money laundering and whatnot
i don't claim to know the inside
workings of that enough to throw down a
strong opinion but just through the
narrow lens of micro transactions
in which you would want to actually own
something
unique in the game
i don't see how it's not a sort of an
improvement on it no i would agree with
the same i also
well you can't you can sell it you could
sell it within players of that game so
you could also just exist on the service
star citizen had if star citizen added a
second-hand market to their game it
would achieve exactly the same goal
which i think roblox already does yeah
as well i know i mean they're they're
you know they do other things are awful
um
but like there's there's yeah it's it's
the same it's the same functionality and
that's to be fair austin i completely
agree with you like if you removed
the
the if you had it exactly the same
amount of um adjudication
that you'd have on say a credit card
purchase so that people can't be screwed
out of money via it and if you uh if you
made it they didn't have an
environmental impact or had a similar
environmental impact to other forms of
currency and obviously everything has an
environmental impact um i'd be i'd be
absolutely okay with it to be honest
though if you fix those two things
the majority of the people who are
currently trying to work in the space
wouldn't want to work there because
ultimately right now the benefit of this
is the lack of regulation if you look i
i think nfts i don't know the numbers on
my head but the vast bulk of money in
nfcs is owned by like a very i think
it's less than a percent because it's
100 a bunch of people
creating the illusion of a much livelier
marketplace than there is being the
implication is that gamers don't
actually on mass want this
or or have an interest in to me it feels
it feels the same as
you know
the
the
the people who are really excited about
it and evangelizing for it just feel to
me
really not that different from you know
when the iphone first came out and there
was like all the early adopters that you
know were
almost religious in there and they're
evangelizing for it and every there's
often new things that some little
nucleus keeps
they keep it afloat in fact if it's a
really cool thing that's been made
you know the creators of that thing will
often look to that little early adopter
nucleus community and be like we survive
because of you
um now you know again i'm not trying to
paint an overly charitable or optimistic
or rosy picture as if i
care more than i do it's not one of
those things that like i've seen
composer you know musicians
dabbling in it as well and i always am
curious if i'm overlooking a an
entrepreneurial opportunity but it just
struck me as like i don't think this is
something i really feel like investing a
huge amount of time into learning about
um
that um
i do think having your own cool thing is
cooler than a regular microtransaction
that's way cooler if i get my own horse
armor
i like that that's neat um when it comes
to
the people who are the early adopters
ranting and raving about it
the thing that makes it different from
an iphone i think
is that these people are trying to get
you on board to profit from you
almost in a pyramid scheme kind of way
so if they're already involved in
bitcoin and then they go tweet about
bitcoin and they're like hey you gotta
buy bitcoin you guys
you can't take that advice at face value
from anyone who's saying that because as
soon as you buy it theirs is worth more
also iphones are cool
like
like like that's the other one that's
not a clean analogy i'm not i'm not
going to worry i appreciate i'm not
trying to like but i think that's
another there's a
more general thing here and i've seen
this argument made there's a brilliant
graph that a bunch like to point out i'm
using a samsung galaxy but go ahead
other mobile phones uh brands uh exist
but they're not as good as iphones um
the the
i i've people send me this graph of like
internet uptake and and and the argument
they make and it's a it's an interest
it's a compelling argument for the 30
seconds before you think of it like
people used to say the internet had no
value and now it's part of everyday life
and you know insect can do all these
things but you could you could go
remember when they said heath ledger
couldn't play the joker exactly it's
that kind of argument and it's a
terrible like
ledger was the nfts of actors is that
yeah alana pierce take it
but it's an argument you see made a lot
and the problem with it is
every bad idea was also treated as a bad
idea when it came up for the first time
right like so it's it's it's kind of
it's an argument from a position of this
thing in the past was good when people
thought it was bad therefore
this bad this thing will everything that
people think will be bad it's a bad
transition it's a bad transitory
statement makes no sense um and and
that's the i get what you're saying
though it just simply means that you
can't make the you can't that's itself
not an argument is essentially all
you're saying i'm saying that yeah it's
no argument back the bad things were
also bad yeah i would i would be
for me it's just when do we give up
because like you know i've been being
pitched i've been being pitched
specifically nfts within video games for
about three to four years
like events and stuff like they've
they've had people there who are who are
[ __ ] who are trying to sell that as a
concept
and it's the same stuff they've not the
argument's not improved or changed
there's no new examples of games that
have done it really interestingly or
well
and
ultimately it just doesn't solve
anything and and i i still keep my my
brain keeps coming back to the thing the
thing you said lana where it's like oh
you know owning my own horse armor would
be cool it would but that that's not
what this is and it's and that inherent
dishonesty and the way that it's sold to
people as you own this when you
absolutely don't on any level or any
meaningful level
don't even own a game you buy
exactly well that's true as well but at
least with a game you buy if you want to
play it in a lot of cases and this is
something that's changing right but a
lot of case if you can find an old xbox
and you put your disc in it will run
that's obviously not that that's that's
becoming
still playing my n64 games but you do
not own a piece of unique horse armor
and crucially as well it won't be
meaningfully unique because for the
amount of money you would pay for it i'm
not gonna be able to pay a team to make
you a piece of horse armor that's
genuinely unique it's gonna be like from
attack that's why you see all these ugly
kind of monkey and lions right because
it's just it's just bad asset swaps
you can't create meaningful
you can't create ten thousand
meaningfully different characters for a
video game and certainly not in multiple
games
it it's just more work for the devs
which will never be at a large scale to
make ten thousand unique items
so it becomes about absurd it becomes
about stats or it becomes what austin is
saying with star citizen about like a
time locked thing
and that's cool because presumably the
people who make star citizen go okay
well we're gonna make this put this on
sale for two weeks or whatever and we're
gonna charge this amount and we know
a lot of people will buy that we already
do that with pre-orders we do we always
do those things it makes perfect sense
and sources and it's a simple profit and
expenditure they'll go yep that makes
sense but they're not going to make all
of those ships uniquely different
because that carries a cost even if it
is just a stats change um and that not
to mention of course all of the stats
change the number of people who've come
up with that
all the people come up to me at
conferences and say like you'll be able
to buy like your own mario character and
they'll have a they'll have a specific
jump height and a specific amount of
damage they can do and it's like how do
you balance a video game way to destroy
multiplayer gaming
these ideas don't tend to become but
that's where ultimately that that's
where
that's where ultimately the players
would be the arbiter of of that real
fast i mean people wouldn't want to play
a game that has that kind of
you know
sort of chaos injected into it and they
would i feel like i feel like they'd
just stop playing or they'd be like kind
of like how there's pvp servers and
non-pvp servers on mmos you know they'd
be like here's the chaos wild west nft
server where people can buy their crazy
stat
you know
like
you know pcp characters that can do
anything and then uh and then uh here's
like the normal balanced game that we
actually spent 10 years making but
that's going to create interesting
things right like so you're absolutely
right
like on the saturday night live the all
drugs olympics
like even without my bookshelf by the
way i can still do it
[Music]
nice um
it's a magic it's just skills
i own something they go away
and i can
but even that creates really interesting
dynamics interesting in like an awful
way of like if you've bought if you've
bought like your characters this these
boots that make you jump higher you've
been told these boots can be transported
into every game and then when you go
into a game
you've got them and it's brilliant fun
but then you know the developers nerf
your boots that you've bought it's
annoying look at how annoyed players are
when that when we as game developers
like nerf the stats on their favorite
gun in a first person shooter imagine if
that's something they own
and have or think they own because they
read the small print and they see
themselves they see me taking something
from them at that point so that would be
fascinating that's going to be and the
blockchain doesn't stop you from making
changes or from patching things
nope you can still change whatever you
want that's what people don't seem to
understand is is
that book my copy of the snl oral
history that i just held up that book i
own it i bought it i have it in my
possession
and if i walk around the world with it i
can read it and i can have my
time with it if i'm carrying an object
uh in a virtual space
the laws of physics are defined by the
people who made the game the laws of the
universe are defined i can make it that
when you walk into my game
your book is going to turn into
something completely different or it's
going to be torn into shreds
we we
when you say to someone you will own
this you imply a permanence that is not
going to be the case in any video game
context because that's not how any
virtual world works there is no
there's not even it's like saying you'll
never take the servers offline
exactly
exactly that but i i feel but but surely
i mean but all that is still true in a
world of micro transactions and it's the
reason people don't like micro
transactions or the reason a lot and
that's why if you don't like them
and and similarly people don't play
games that that leverage them if they
don't like that's where i look at it and
i go there's sort of i look at it as a
curiosity that i don't find particularly
threatening because i just think if if
it offers something valuable
then people will find ways to do cool
[ __ ] with it and if it ultimately is
some shell game or a ponzi scheme
the players are gonna you know there
might be this little window where people
get fleeced obviously and that sucks and
and you know everyone should be careful
with how they use their money but like
it won't survive that window
after the initial excited early adopters
if they get screwed
you know
it i just don't see how it won't fail
unless it offers something valuable like
i think that's what you're saying will
be borne out by experience with i mean
this is me and austin 100 like
your free market kind of perspective and
your your ideas that you know ultimately
people the bible where and if if someone
messes up there they should be kind of
the ultimate test of the free market
isn't it because it's like obviously i'm
coming from a political place which is
way off to the other direction of like
no we should probably have safety nets
and protect people from bad actors and
which is the opposite side of i'm not
saying one's better or worse but it's
interesting that even on nfcs like you
can see the difference in our
perspective on how problems are solved
on like a population level so it's
interesting it's an interesting
difference
for what it's worth i do think that
consumer protection is a good thing if
only from uh
from a
at minimum
and i i wouldn't stop here but at
minimum a
an education on what you're getting into
before you
before you spend that money and if you
choose to say you know what i have i
have some fun money if i want to throw a
thousand dollars around on an nft or 50
or 100 or 10 000 or whatever you know
then that's when i say go for it and if
you spend it and it goes to [ __ ] and
you're like well that [ __ ] sucks i'm
gonna go tweet so the whole world knows
that that was a [ __ ] idea like
the system will auto correct okay you
know because again we're not talking
about we're not talking about something
that people's lives hang in the balance
on i think that i think like i said i
think it's a difference in like i don't
think the system's auto correct i don't
believe that's true but that's a bigger
conversation
but in this case how not though because
players would simply stop either playing
the games that lean on this heavily or
they would just stop using this
system of the game in the way so for
example ponzi ponzi schemes in the real
world right like pyramid schemes um
what's it called now what's the new
phrase for it
but not vertical marketing um
they changed it oh multi multi-level
multi mlm yeah mlm which is which is
just a pyramid scheme um it's a part of
the scheme yeah yeah so those have
existed
forever right i don't actually know what
the origin story of those is but like a
hundred years right
we as a society we have education that
those are bad
uh there's been lots of examples of it
being bad
millions of people throughout history
have lost money on those schemes because
they always do because it's uh an awful
thing
there's been no auto correction 100
years
society-wide for pyramid schemes they
still exist and are still profitable for
bad actors so that system hasn't
autocorrected i don't think that's a
good example though i mean the
like as
free markets depend on there being
enforcement of
of of like fraud is illegal
ponzi schemes are never
there's no defense of a ponzi scheme
under that kind of like if someone
defrauds you yeah um
then they are in the wrong in all cases
like there's no they still there's no
continue to act and make billions and
have conferences and well that's but but
that's like saying
we haven't solved war we haven't solved
disease we like human the human
experience is still fundamentally the
same there's always going to be people
that are fundamentally [ __ ] who are
trying to leverage them
let me reframe it for you pyramid
schemes have not gotten less successful
in 100 years
we've not made progress we've made
progress well i would actually i would
argue they they've probably become more
successful short term because things
like the internet have probably made it
easier to fleece a lot of people at once
but again that's just
in the same way that nuclear bombs have
made it easier to kill people in a short
order relative to swords and bows and
arrows like yeah that's just the
tragedy of technology that can help us
as well as hinder us so economic systems
are not auto correcting is what you're
saying
i
no that's not what i'm saying i'm saying
i think that
over the grand scheme
bad
all i'm saying at least in the context
of nfts is bad products brought to
market that are non-coercively offered
and non-fraudulently represented will
fail if they don't
prove to have some kind of value
to the people involved in that
transaction okay and sometimes it takes
a while for that value to bear itself
out or not
and there are pros and cons to that and
i would never proclaim to be some
pure zealot that says that the systems
are perfect but i do think that when
things are offered non-coercively and
there's nothing that says you must buy
this nft in this game or whatever that's
like no i choose to try it or not okay
or my buddy did he lost money and that
sucked and my character argument is that
is self-correcting over time my argument
my counter argument to that is a similar
pyramid scheme structure
has not decreased over time as you said
has actually increased probably i don't
know the numbers on that so i wouldn't
make that statement but it's not
decreased
over 100 years which implies that no the
market
and consumers don't auto correct or
share information in a way that makes
them less susceptible to bad actors
um but that's my concern well i don't
there's been books written on both of
our perspectives like this we're not
i think i learned something in the
middle and my thing is
there's so much money in it that i
actually think
nfts are inevitable um and that this is
what we're headed towards and the reason
that i see it as a threat is that nfts
feed directly into uh service games live
service games everything being online
the death of single player all this
cliche [ __ ] that we talk about nfts lead
straight to that future where you get
your instead of assassin's creed 2 you
have your assassin's creed infinite um
and i think
the only reason that i would think if
they didn't provide
inherent
objective value that i could see
uh is that there's so much money in
marketing that you can so easily tell
people there's value and they'll believe
it so even if there isn't an inherent
value that i can see in my horse armor
being purple when someone's is like a
slightly lighter purple
um
you can be tricked into thinking that's
valuable because there's so much money
in the marketing of that thing and
humans
are so susceptible to marketing you can
be told that you're uncool if you don't
have something and then you'll go buy
the thing cool isn't [ __ ] tangible
and that's when they already have so
much money from the jump in
aaa publishing or whatever else and
they're gonna try and tell me hey you
gotta do i mean it works with ultimate
team you don't actually own those
players
but people think it's cool they think
that they have to thus you feel
compelled to buy them regardless of what
they have value though i guess then you
could make a case for well the value is
feeling cool or feeling like you're a
part of ultimate team or feeling like
you see these players like
technically that's value but but my
thing is i think this is going to happen
i think we are
full steam ahead unavoidable because the
companies who are interested in it have
too much [ __ ] money facebook for
example
that
we are going to have this stuff marketed
to us in a way that they will make us
want them and if we think we don't
they'll change the marketing strategy
and it's done like i've already given up
it's happening
because they've decided it's valuable
and profitable they will trick us into
thinking it is yeah
and i think we're relatively easy to no
it's
proven we are very easily tricked by
marketing
i think right now my take on it and then
i i'm ready to be wrong on this because
i think i probably will be um
right now i think it's it's it's
interesting watching and just in the
game spaces i'm definitely not qualified
to be on the game space
um
the
every ceo has done the press press
release saying we are looking into this
we are thinking about this we are
considering this we are exploring our
options because right now um investors
are
aware of the term mnft and there's a
market reason for them to express that
position
um those that have tried it so far in
the game space have massively failed
like it's just not worked because the
audience isn't interested because if
you're not artificially inflating these
numbers there isn't a marketplace for
them um and that's and because because
with thing to say i know but because
triple a have quite high ethical
standards when it comes to uh literal
fraud they've not they've their stuff
has very visibly kind of failed so i
i remain hopeful that this can't cross
over simply because there isn't actually
any demand from
consumers for it and actually
from a from a big company point of view
it's much better for them to have
complete ownership of the servers and
the
the means of sale for the goods they're
selling so i'm i'm i think it's a fad i
hope it's a fad but i'm also very aware
of all the millions of people in history
who've said things are fads that they've
become i think we're going full matrix
man yeah
i think we're going 100 percent
but this is when people
you know like when the very first mmos
took off and it was like this is all
future video games now
because it was like a new business model
you know you can pay twenty dollars a
month
you could buy somebody's world of
warcraft character for ten thousand
dollars ages ago which is pretty similar
just not everyone i'm pretty sure to be
just correct austin there i'm pretty
sure mmos were invented about a month
ago and they're called the metaverse i
don't think
the first the first wedding in a video
game happened two weeks ago was reported
in the new york times the final fantasy
economy is an interesting one there are
a limited amount of houses
and thus
all of the rich people have already
bought out all of the houses
and so the economy in the game is like
it's fascinating it's super [ __ ] up
because there's no entry point for any
new players to buy houses games are
getting too realistic
it's a problem
i mean the eve
like that stuff's
multi-level people losing ten thousand
dollars in a day because of a a
sabotage attack that was planned over
the course of a year it's really
interesting to read about it's brilliant
like the book i love the problem in the
book which is the history of that
universe and the the awful like way
players are treating each other i love
it though it's fascinating i just feel
like that's kind of what you sign up for
with eve right when you're going to eat
expecting that kind of thing i feel like
i'm looking
right now at a decision of
do i buy land
in the meta right now
to make sure that in
10 years i can just profit from that as
passive income the same as real estate
and sell my soul and feel like [ __ ] for
it or do i regret it in 10 years that i
didn't do it
that is genuinely where i think we're at
what is what is
what what about it
i get that you're dubious of the whole
thing but what about the selling of the
soul is the environmental impact
specifically ah okay right sure yeah
because it gets astronomically worse the
more of the stuff that we play with as
well so like it feels like the active
acceleration of climate change to
contribute to this machine otherwise i
would just see it in stock it's philip k
dick would write this and we'd all be
that's a little longer though he's going
to get dick like during during the
during the last kind of stages of uh
global warming we would invent a
currency that required global warming to
exist i i would give i'd actually taking
all that putting all that aside i would
and this is just me breaking characters
completely the warren buffett kind of
recommendation which is invest in what
you know
if you don't if you if you're investing
in something because you
you feel based on other people's
opinions that it's worth investing in
then you probably are not going to be
able to tell the difference between a
good investment or a bad investment you
should sure you should invest in stuff
what you should be investing in atlanta
is like stuff where you feel qualified
to know the difference between a good
and excellent because that's the other
thing that's worth remembering with with
all investments
is
and this is where all of the passive
income youtubers that exist are awful is
no one makes steady money off the stock
market unless they're making excellent
bets consistently because the margins
are so small so
yes could you live to regret not
investing in something sure but you
could equally live to regret not you
know spent wasting money or something i
bought bitcoin in 2017 and made a lot of
money
um and i didn't understand it which is
not a good case for doing that
repeatedly it's one fluke
uh that might be your flight that might
be your reference that might be your one
fleet that might have to be clear i
haven't done it my intention if i were
to invest in anything would
and i would do real land
or gold
something that doesn't like
astronomically
more consistently reliable
yes on the long term of human history um
i i just
entered that idea
near the coast
inland inland
yeah the future coast
what they call futures training oklahoma
that's right yeah yeah exactly
just to put it just to put a button on
it to make sure that my
point was
not unclear um
i uh i felt like we were kind of talking
past each other because it felt like
what you were describing
was a disappointment in fundamental
human nature and like the capacity for
people to
to harm each other through
ponzi schemes and and whatever else
um
uh whereas i think i've i
and like it's saying that it's sort of
it's sort of the technology's
responsibility to prevent that or to
mitigate that whereas i see it as humans
will always find a way
um and it's far better to focus on what
the upswing is of the wave things that
can be can be used to bring value and
meaning and positive uh
impacts to people's lives knowing that
it's unpredictable how some conniving
[ __ ] will find a way to use it there
will always be that person because
humans are kind of human it like to me
that's
that's the the whole sales pitch of the
free market is on the basis that the
positive will outweigh the negative
because people are
engaged in
voluntary
transactions and and as long as you have
an enforcement of
you know
property rights and things like you know
uh
uh fraud being illegal always you know
like you can't just lie to someone and
be told ah well you know
so i completely to be clear like i agree
the only the only place your description
of my position differs is i don't think
technology has any responsibility
because technology is it's a hammer it's
who's holding it that ultimately makes
the decision about how it's used yeah
and i don't i don't mean to misrepresent
you because i agree with that yeah the
only difference i think in what we're
saying is i think you and i think this
is honestly just it's i don't think one
is
better or worse than i think it's just
two different ways of looking at things
i think you put a little bit more
emphasis on individual responsibility
and i put a little bit more um
importance on um
uh you know i guess judicial or kind of
uh cultural political uh responsibility
i think i think uh
the kind of oversights you're talking
about are crucial i think capitalism can
work if it's got ridiculous amounts of
limitations on the bad actors
um the free market
it becomes a definition there is no
market is actually free except
you know a market like like uh like nfts
where there is no oversight right now
fraud is legal in the nft world
by definition because there's no one
there's no oversight there's no way of
tracking
um a lot of what goes on so right now
it's very easy to commit those crimes
and my argument would just be to hey we
should we should have exactly the same
kind of limiters on this marketplace as
we do on the real world marketplace with
all the tanks and you know uh countries
backing it up rather than just kind of
individuals it's an interesting summary
yeah because i don't i don't know that i
necessarily disagree my but you i think
your summary of our different
perspectives is right because my first
instinct is if if if it's really easy
for things to go really horribly wrong
for the user and the nft space
my first instinct is to just say well
tread lightly
but you're right that is that is an
individual responsibility kind of take
uh i think i think right now
yeah i think we're a brit talking to an
american right now and i i don't think
there's a there i think it's just it's
just a different kind of perspective on
the same stuff well and i'm not opposed
you know i'm not anti-regulatory
uh
constructs you know i'm not i don't
think i mean that's sort of like
civilization is better than like
you know the primordial ooze you know i
mean
that's the highest sake of the show
that's the title of the episode
civilization is better than primordial
ooze
i hear you yeah come on where's my
where's my uh
animated uh
that's all it's gonna be it's just
monkey heads floating
uh weighing of civilization versus sort
of like
pre-pre-humanity
all right so arcane
i think it's ethically uh i think it's
great it's [ __ ] brilliant it's
beautiful it's it's incredibly well
produced it's did you both finish i've
still more um two more so maybe we'll
maybe we'll do it next week
i will say the first three episodes i
was like i don't like this that much
because i was very annoyed by
some of the tropes with the kids
um i was like okay
you've got the like oh no please let me
help oh why won't you let me help where
they leave and they say no you have to
stay home and then they show up anyway
how many times does that [ __ ] happen
i was like okay i'm i'm so used to this
um vi also being like this tough woman
with the shave side to the head you seen
boxing i was like
what come on um and then it all paid off
and i i have to say
potential spoiler maybe warning maybe
slightly
i was so mad when i realized she was
jinx
i was like you kept calling her at jinx
and she has the blue head i didn't
connect the league of legends character
as [ __ ] jinx because you kept calling
a powder i was like [ __ ] like it's so
obvious i couldn't believe i didn't
realize that
[ __ ] hell because i should have been
like oh it's jinx she's gonna go evil
which actually is an interesting thing
that i've seen people say about arcane
if you played a lot of league league of
legends the show isn't as good
just because you have too much knowledge
of where it's going or and how
characters turn out right well and it
feels like the show has been made i
don't know i'm not a big expert on
league uh but i i
it strikes me as the show is basically a
standalone
we are not beholden to the in-game canon
in this ultra rigorous way like we are
drawing inspiration but creating
something for because you know angela
and i both watched it and were glued to
it and and and as neither of us are big
play i mean she's got way more info than
i do because she's done the cosplay
world so much and these characters are
everywhere and she's herself cosplayed a
lot of a lot of league of legends
characters but
but uh still not a huge player and i i
for sure are not um and
i found that they did such an amazing
job at not making that a hindrance it
doesn't feel like a video it's
interesting that it's actually maybe
even so far the other direction yeah
it's actually helped me yeah again i
obviously i i used to play a little bit
of league i haven't played in ages i
know who jinx is there are plenty of
characters that i wouldn't know i
remember um
but like with her yeah if you had put it
together or you played league more often
and you're like blue hair she's got
these striped
pants that she wears and they call her a
jinx
i definitely watching the show i
remember turning to kerry like halfway
through the first episode being like
okay so there's definitely i don't know
anything about you guys
there's a blue head little jinx who
throws grenades in that game i know that
already from this so i i'm judging you a
little bit i'll be honest well the issue
is not actually
with the blue head character called jinx
it's that powder
as a character was not like jinx right
okay so i had the separation of the two
um and then i
when when she said i don't have to
finish you have to i will yeah yeah
where they where they where it goes
it's just beautiful it's just so good i
was so blown away it was also thinking
about the amount of characters they
introduced in a really short amount of
time was the thing that i as a writer
was like
wow okay i understand who all of these
people are you're showing me sometimes
three or four different perspectives in
two episodes and i'm following all of
them um super well
the comparison to game of thrones i
think is overused when talking about
literally anything with a political
dimension or like intrigue but this felt
so game of thrones in the sense of like
you said pacing us through introducing
us
telling that world the thing i noticed i
thought was really cute was how much
like game of thrones that first episode
you don't see any characters that aren't
human you don't see i think you see like
one or two figures like in the corner
frame but like mostly it's very standard
very almost feels like it's set in uh
you know old france basically rather
than like a fantasy kingdom and that
second episode they push so you know and
it just slowly but surely kind of builds
and stacks that stuff and which and then
yeah say the characters up as well so
it's fascinating from a production point
of view my god like it's everything is
just done in the most expensive way
possible like totally the the effects
work the 2d animation effects work is
like that's craft that just doesn't
exist in tv or film anymore like you do
not do dust clouds by hand anymore
unless you're this show because you're
spending all the money on it it's crazy
it's
cool it makes me excited about
excited it's so hard to talk it makes me
excited about
all the extra stuff riot is doing right
now
uh if this is that good and they're
making a single player game uh which
you're doing
a whole bunch of different stuff because
they shot the ip around to like indie
studios and other studios right i
remember like they're doing they've got
a few things going on right yeah with a
bunch of different people yeah i'm
excited to see what they make
there's something else that i haven't
researched the details of this yet but
one of the first things that jumped out
at me when watching the show and the
first time the credits roll is that the
like
top level showrunner creator of this
show is christian link who got started
with riot as one of their composers
and i was like how the [ __ ] did this
happen i've never seen that why was i
i've never seen
well just have never i mean he's been
very you know tied in with with riot for
10 plus years but i
um and i had seen his name less and less
uh over the last few years which
suggested to me he had migrated higher
into the
into the you know the more
not admin but like the sort of creative
leadership as opposed to um you know the
the rank and file uh creators of
executors of the art as it were
um and uh because yeah i was like wow
what a he's i've actually funny i've
never met him i know i know a bunch of
the people that have worked with riot
i've worked with ryan in fact i kept
going when they gonna introduce my i
wrote one of those champion themes when
are they going to bring my character out
and uh see if they uh did that happen
did you have your things do you have
your thing no no i i did the i did the
theme for vola bear who they
reintroduced at the beginning of the
pandemic and uh i think uh it could be a
long time before we see volibear on
arcane but uh
um but yeah no it was it was um it was i
was like damn i wanna i want to um
know more details about how the the
composer kind of migrated into this
position of like literally this is my
show because that's a hell of a thing
this isn't just any show it's like one
of the clearly
top shows uh you know of the year i mean
across all ways you could analyze it's
so good i i was like [ __ ] hell a plus
man good for you and it makes sense in
retrospect like it's not something i
feel about when i was watching but it it
is very music driven right like the the
music the school the kind of it feels it
feels like someone with that mindset
would do
without
the imagined dragons
no not imagination
fine with imagine dragons i don't think
that song suits the show
and every time i find it jarring
it's it's funny i i
yeah sometimes i feel that way uh and
and i was what was i watching recently
um
i as i was watching i was watching um
i'd never seen how i met your mother
before and recently was watching
episodes of it and like occasionally
they have really sort of heartfelt you
know where they don't go for laughs at
the end of the episode so it ends kind
of quietly but then their sort of
generic very upbeat
title theme comes in over the ending
credits and it's very it's just a
symptom of old-fashioned like i remember
breaking bad being very interesting
about how they always did different yes
entitles music on every episode so that
it never felt out of step when the
episode was ending yeah yeah yeah for
sure and so it was like
to me that you know this does have a
slightly old-fashioned tv quality in
that in that regard because that theme
is sort of like this abstraction of the
show
that exists
separately from the actual sort of
events of a given episode
but otherwise musically you know alex
temple so this is a funny thing in the
world of
being a contemporary composer there's
this there's this thing of vsts virtual
instruments which is basically you know
if i want to
write an orchestral piece but i don't
want to hire or i can't hire an actual
orchestra you can create well you know a
mock-up or you can create a a you know
depending on how good you are a
reasonably realistic
games with a lobbyist season
some of us yeah well
some some some some impressive triple a
games do too
uh or orchestral recordings are
definitely not a not an automatic given
um but um
but years ago like well over 10 years
ago there was this guy
um who
you know there if you like so
it was funny
there were two composers if you if you
googled the name alex temple like more
than 10 years ago two composers would
show up there was like this composer who
was based in i want to say chicago who
was uh
i i can't remember where she's living
now but there was alex compo alex temple
the composer she now goes by lexi i
think
um i'm i'm possibly getting that wrong
um but like of the academic world um you
know sort of so-called
modern classical music you know very
very um
um
some really great music actually um uh
not a given in that world um but uh but
uh definitely not so so-called
commercial music and then the other alex
temple was this guy who
basically was just the best vst dude you
could imagine like you he would upload
mock-ups of like okay i tried doing you
know
stravinsky's rite of spring with the
latest uh sample libraries from
east west and here's how it turned out
and you'd listen to it and you go [ __ ]
me if that's not a recording of like the
[ __ ] berlin philharmonic like
he his mock-ups were head and shoulders
and it's somewhere along the way he got
plugged in with the riot folks and
started working on music for league of
legends and um
and he's the composer of the show now
and there are some cues in that
again i don't i can't since i don't
quite remember where it fell on the show
and neither of you have finished i won't
say what but there are a few scenes
where i literally like stopped it and
and and was like i hope they put that
out on spotify because that that is a
[ __ ] that's an emmy worthy cue uh
like
it's amazing that this person who i
first heard of over a decade ago
who was just basically good with their
computers has made their way into
position
a piece of music in a media production
okay why
call it queue it's cues off an event in
the in the show so it's based on the
timing of it
it's it no it's just that's just that's
just the that's just the ter i i i
actually don't know the original um like
probably 1920s origin of the term but
cues they're often
another old school term is they're
referred to as starts like oh we have 17
starts in this movie like there's music
fresh a fresh piece of music that we
record and you know proceed start to
finish starts 17 times interesting um as
as distinguished from needle drops or
licensed music
where you're
you know licensing some song and that's
playing on a radio in the background or
playing on screen or somebody's singing
on screen you wouldn't typically call
those cues it's the composer writing the
score is writing queues interesting so
like the way old-fashioned
uh movies would work where you would
have a
um
a reel of footage that ran for 18 or so
minutes uh that you know like when you
if you know
depending on how old one is uh when you
would go to the movie theaters every 20
minutes or so you'd occasionally see a
little circle appear in the corner and
that's the real change that being being
uh warned of uh and the good
projectionists obviously you know that's
the thing they're looking for and and on
they're on top of it so there's no break
in the projection of the movie well when
you're working on the movie you're also
working in reels so the old-fashioned
way that they would label cues
is like the first cue of the movie which
in you know old-fashioned terms would be
your main title sequence or even the
overture if it's a sufficiently
old-fashioned movie where you've got you
know just main titles come up big piece
of music plays that's called one m1 so
you would meaning
real one
first piece of music um and so
interestingly there's two schools of
thought on how to number those because
some people have like a global number so
if the first piece of if you have five
pieces of music in real one and then 22
minutes into the movie is now we're in
real two and you've got your sixth piece
of music the question is is that
2m
6
meaning real to the sixth piece of music
or is it 2m1 the first piece of music of
real two interesting uh and i've always
thought it
makes sense to have uh
pieces of music that are real specific
because if you add like if i add a sixth
piece in real one it [ __ ] up the entire
numbering scheme for the rest of the
movie if if i have a running total it's
like
the right numbered lines of code so you
have like line 10 do this line 20 do
that line 22 do this like 23 do that
like 30 do that line 40 and you have to
kind of cram them in the gaps yeah same
thing
yeah
exactly and so anyway so q is is just
always the term for because it's not
accurate to call them you know songs and
and it's not accurate to call that i
mean sometimes cues are songs but that
but
could it literally have been like the
cue for the dude on the piano in the
theater to start playing generic comedy
track number two was it like was it
there's a lot of things
was it that original there's a lot of
there that that's actually a really
accurate guess and it's possible this is
one of those things that i've read so
many books on the history of
film music that i i probably just have
forgotten this piece of trivia but that
that's a really good guess given that a
lot of our
a lot of the film music traditions are
basically tumbled out of the live silent
theater
accompanist tradition
um such a rich history and uh because so
yeah djing which is what sparked me to
ask
is
if i hit the q button i can hear the
playback in my headphones of the next
song that i might be trying to queue up
so it doesn't play for everybody else
but i can hear it ahead of time to make
sure that i can beat match up whatever
else um
same word different definition yeah it's
about the same it's literally the cue
button
and here in the uk queueing is a natural
a national pastime that's something we
do for fun we'll just kind of line up
outside somewhere
well the funny thing is that that oh
yeah well we spell everything
differently here it's fine it's it's
it's
q-u-e-u-e yeah
yeah
very differently spelled but i see
people all the time
mix those because they'll say oh i
really liked that queue in that movie
and they'll spell it out
i was just kidding
you're trying too hard here
oh yeah no it's anyway point point being
there are cues there are pieces of music
in arcane that i was completely
uh blown away by where i just thought
man they they are not
um
i think they're just going for it
it just it's it it is it i just love
that it's so unashamedly
like we're gonna score this like it
isn't
it is an old-fashioned epic feel that
way about the writing the acting is also
very good and the animation is very
unique but yeah they really [ __ ] went
for it i feel like if it doesn't get
award nominated or doesn't win
ugh
keep going
if it doesn't it's just that
anti-animation bias or anti-video game
bias i don't i don't everyone's paid off
you're wrong well the animation is real
is it is hilarious watching awards shows
like with with with friends and my
partner in the animation industry like
the amount animation is overlooked by
the rest of the film industry is
astonishing like it's crazy
yeah it's usually not interestingly it's
not usually the case uh for music if you
want to win an oscar for for best score
scoring a pixar film is uh often your
best bet for getting at least on the
list the michael giaccino awards for
being michael giaccino yeah
yeah he yeah he won his oscar for
he won his oscar for up uh you know
thomas newman's been nominated a million
times he's actually i think the most
nominated
person who's never won i think in the
whole academy um
and um
because he's nominated like 16 times or
something and uh
with no wins though um he's very but but
a couple of those were like wally and
blah blah blah a couple of your favorite
records those aren't animators no but i
was like i bought them and i was like
austin i bought these
these are the two bestsellers i see star
trek four you got the leonard rosen i
love that i know it's the one that
people hate but i love that soundtrack
that fanfare
is amazing it's social i just always
remember the very silly the very silly
kind of quasi-mozart music as they're
escaping the hospital oh it's ridiculous
oh it's crazy so it's like star trek
comedy but
like so yeah you know i mean even even
um even han zimmer you know people think
of him as today he's you know he's the
interstellar
the the you know maybe pirates of the
caribbean but mostly these high prestige
you know inception interstellar dunkirk
blah blah but he won his one and only
oscar for the lion king 30 years ago
that's a great soundtrack
yeah music is one of those
yeah but partly honestly people
the academy is just as human as
everybody else they're not they are not
more sophisticated
in their voting patterns than than you
would guess and so the bottom line is if
you score a movie
that has music very forward-facing
then they'll notice it and they'll go oh
yeah i remember that there was music
the movie they that everyone saw with
their grandkids as well right like
that's the other aspect is like every i
mean
yeah because they don't have to worry
when they can just watch a minute there
was that
there was that french
silent film called the artist um that
literally had
you know this
big lush orchestral score as literally
the only audio that you heard in the
movie so it was not exactly a shock when
that won the oscar in 2012
that film was like cleaned up right like
i remember that one i've not seen it and
i don't it's just culturally just
disappeared like it was one of those one
of those oscar movies that was massive
and then just kind of i don't feel
anyone talks about them
my agent has a whole
running gag about that where he's like
you could do a whole trivia on oscar
winners who no one remembers yeah
like because sometimes you just are in
the right place at the right time
there's like nice hits right yeah
yep and but i don't think i i don't feel
like that will be the case with arcane
arcane could easily be one of those that
fits in the like jimi hendrix category
of
sustained
interest
you know well outlived by themselves but
actually didn't win previously
awards you
that i think has probably gone
i think it's probably oh yeah i mean
netflix i think had by far the greatest
number netflix and amazon both i think
were competing for the most number of
total emmy nominations across all their
various categories yeah but previously
they weren't even considered so that's a
win oh it's wild it's not an exponential
shift it was not there
it's wrong but that's the horror movie
it's everything it's a bias against you
know the people we like getting good
things but it is also funny because the
word bias
the way that we use it really just means
opinion
it's their opinions agenda i feel like
yes it is yes that's exactly what i
wanted them to do there for their bias
bias
it's the same as when people qualify
what they're going to say by but look
this is just my opinion
i always think you know
i yeah i i we're not i gather this is
not a peer-reviewed statement you're
about to offer up i i'm i'm i'm banking
on that
i would promise that we will talk about
arcane next week but i can't make
promises to our audience i'm not going
to continue to lie to you i'd love to
who knows
um
we'll talk about [ __ ] and then we know
hey guys uh do you want to do the last
of us part two spoiler cast next week
i'm off next week you can do it
i'll take i'll take one for the team
i'll skip
uh
um
i think you taking one for the team
would be playing through it and
finishing it that's true
i i i'm a good man but i'm not a great
man austin
oh well it's still too depressing to
play through the last of his part two
it's fair
um but merry christmas everybody
i will
actually edit the animated thing into
this video but i'll also release it
separately and there are more of them
coming i think it's really good it's
really good yeah congrats congrats to
him i'm wonderful i apologize that i
already forgot matt ringstead
matt
well bravo it's really hilarious super
cool um we will see you all next week
merry christmas merry christmas